هو ده ابدا
بالشكر الرئيس يونس ومضيفا الروماني همم
صديقي وزير الخارجيه على كرم الضيافه
وكذلك على هذه الشركه ليست اليوم بل في كل
يوم
بزيارتي كانت في ال همم 97 كنت مع الرئيس
واعلن عن الشراكه واتذكر ذلك اليوم وكانه
كان يوم امس
كان همم تجمع همم تحت همم الشمس همم
الجميع وقف في ساحه واسعه وتقدم وتعهدات
وهمم كان هناك تعهد كبير وهو ان امريكا
ستبقى الى جانبكم بعد 25 سنه همم نقدر تلك
الشراكه واا عملنا معا لبناء هذه الشركه
على سنوات ال 25 القادمه ايضا عندما نفكر
بان 25 سنه مره
مذهله
التي قطعت كل هذا الشوط الشوط من العلاقات
الاقتصاديه
وفي مجال الطاقه والاستثمارات اااه وهذه
الشركه عزيزتها
مبادرات دوريه
التي تستضيفها رومانيا في 23
العلاقات
الرجال الاعمال
والقطاعات المختلفه الذين كانوا يتنقلون
بين البلدين على ماده تلك القنوات
وعلاقه القائمه على مبادئ المشتركه ولا
شركه
والنقوم ببناء
مؤسسات الديمقراطيه ومحاربه الفساد في
روما عليها الولايات المتحده لا ما كانت
لتتمنى بان يكون لها حديث من مثل هذه
الالتزام فنحن نعمل على تعزيز التحالف
ونعمل معا في عمليات البحر الاسود التي
مركز
ونقف متحدين امام حرب
بوتن
الغاشمه على اوكرانيا ونحن نعمل بسرعه
وتنسيق وعزيمه وايرادات في دعم اوكرانيا
امام وجهه العدوان الروسي وتقديم
المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا لمساعدتهم في
تحقيق ماربهم
وعملنا بايضا بفرده
عقوبات الغير مسبوقه
وكذلك همم
الطاقه والكهرباء وقفنا جميعا لدعم
اوكرانيات وفي هذا كله شاركتنا مع رومانيا
كانت حساسه ومهمه وفتحت ابوابها
الاطفال والنساء وكل من فروا من وجه العنف
لي هنا في رومانيا
قدمت المياه
والغذاء والوقود
لاحتياجات الاوكرانيين
وست مليون طن من الحبوب الاوكرانيه تم
المساعده في نقلها ورومانيا تستضيف همم
مقره دوليه
لتعزيز الدفاعات على
في المنطقه الشرقيه
على هذه على تعزيز الدفاعاته على تعزيز
هذا التحالف نحن نتعاون ونحن نرى ان الحرب
الروسيه هذا هي سبب الازمه ازمه الطاقه
والحكومه الرومانيه همم تعرضت لجماعات همم
الروسيه قامت في هجمات قال لا يوجد دول
كثيره تفهم مثل رومانيا لما لا يجب ان نقف
مع حق جميع الدول صغيره وكبيره في
تحترم سيادتهم وحده اراضيهم و الا يمكن
السماح بمصادره اراضي دول اخرى بالقوه
رومانيه صارت على هذا المسار نحو
الديمقراطيه والان تعتمد على امريكا لتكون
دائما بجانبها هو عندما كان
رئيس
في ذلك الحين همم
قال ان هذه الدول لا يمكن ان تترك لوحدها
حلفاءته همم يبقون معانا كل اراضيته ونقدر
قياده همم
قدمناه نحو همم 200 مليار من مساعدات
رومانيا
للقوات الولايات المتحده هنا في رومانيا
وايضا قدمنا نحو 48 مليون دولار من
المساعدات في برنامج المساعدات المقدم عبر
رومانيا للاجئين الاوكرانيين 27
للطاقه
وهذا
لتؤكد الولايات المتحده انها لا يمكن ان
تترك حليفا دون امن في الطاقه
وايضا هذا هذه علاقات تجاريه ستعمل على
ايجاد فرص عمل للالاف في بلديه وعندما
صرنا همم معرض
متنقل يحتفي بهذه الشركه على مدى 25 سنه
في
قبل هذه الشعب الروماني اللي يقف في وجه
النظام وارسل
كلينتون في ذلك الحين مساعدات وقاموا
كانوا هناك افراد اسر تم اطلاق النار
عليهم
اااه
انهارت انهار حكمهم وحلت الديمقراطيه
وبقيت هذه الدوله دوله موحده
الان
دعونا نستذكر
اللحظات القادمه وهي عبر الوحده ستبقى
وسيبقون مثالا للجميع
ثانكيو انا كويسه شكرا معلم الاسئله
للبحر الاسود وما هي همم
هذه الوثيقه كيف وضعها بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده والكونغرس وسلسله الموافقه عليها
وماذا عن تموضع القوات
وسائل رومانيا
للوضع كيف تحدثتم فيه عندما نتحدث عن
منطقه البحر الاسود هذه المنطقه ذات اهميه
كبيره استراتيجيه
هناك ثلاث من دول الحلفاء الدول الافريقيه
همم
جورج
البحر الاسود الا منطقه منطقه حربيه
بقوه
الروسيه توقف
الموانئ الاوكرانيه لتمنع تصدير الحبوب
والغذاء الاوكراني
ونرقيبه بجد
تمكنا
من اعاده الحركه الى موانئ البحر الاسود
سيتم تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
العالمم
سنعزز وجودنا
من البحر الاسود الى
بلطيق وفي ذلك الجهد نحن نعمل بشكل متواصل
فيما بيننا وبين دول الحلفاء
شكرا شكرا
في البحر الاسود رومانيا مساهم كبير في
هذا الجهد والجهد الموسع بان يكون لدينا
اقوى تحالف دفاعيه عندما نتحدث عن الناتو
يساهمنا ب 2.5 من اجمل الناتج القومي
للدفاع
والرمانه
بايضا مساهمه في امني البحر الاسود نحن
لدينا العزم
اييه
قوه عسكريه قويه تحميل المنطقه عندما
نتحدثنا عن البحر الاسود وكما اشرت فان
رومانيا تستضيف القوات المتعدده في منطقه
الجنوب الشرقي وكذلك هناك مؤسسات وهناك
وحده للنيترو ااه لديها وحده همم متعدده
الجنسيات ولدينا ايضا قوه مختلفه موجوده
هنا في رومانيا
لاكشي
البحر الاسود عنصر مهم وحساس للدفاع في
نيته واسترجاجيه الناتو لكنها ليست ثابته
بل نواصل تطويرها سواء مباشره في ما بيننا
او لاحقا او او عبر التعاون ثنائي وهذا
عمر سنه نتحدث فيه لاحقا شكرا على هذا
السؤال كما ذكرت في العام الماضي عندما
زرته 24
وناقشنا مشروع
برلكسيجيه امريكيه للبحر الاسود
وتحدثنا عن مساهمه رومانيا ووضع موعد
نهائي اييي وهناك وثيقه شامله حول رؤيه
رومانيا وكيف سيكون الدفاع في البحر
الاسود
وان يكون هناك قوه معززه للدول التي تقع
على البحر الاسود
وتحدثنا بالافكار حول تطوير الاقتصادات في
منطقه البحر الاسود
البحر الاسود مركز ومنطقه عبور بين اوروبا
واسيا الوسطى ومنطقه القوقاز اه
مهمه جدا بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا ثبت اهميه هذا التعاون
وراينا كيف يجب ان تكون هناك عطر واضحه
للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه على البحر الاسود
فهي ليست استراتيجيه امريكيه فقط بل اكثر
من ذلك وتتجاوز ذلك
فهي الرؤيه امريكيه
فنحن نقدر انفتاح الولايات المتحده في عرض
هذه الاستراتيجيه والرؤيه
واننا ايضا وضعنا بالصوره في هذه
الاستراتيجيه
وتحدثنا ايضا عن رؤيه رومانيا في هذه
وهذا عرض في وثيقه عرضت نوفمبر الماضي ان
يكون هذا همم مفيد
لصالح
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه
فهي ليست لمصلحه الولايات المتحده
الكونجرس
والتشريعات المتعلقه همم بالاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه
والتقيته
على هامش قمه همم
في الاول من عندما
اول اجتماع على
همم استواحل البحر الاسود بعد قمه مدريد
وكذا امر مهم جدا ورؤيه الرومانيه ستؤخذ
بالاعتبار في هذا في هذه الاستراتيجيه
شكرا
من فرنسا
هناك همم
[موسيقى]
والولايات المتحده في مباريات كاس العالم
المظاهرات التي
تستمر منذ اشهر في ايران
جاي جاي
السياسيه لهذه المباراه
والاتحاد الامريكي لكره القدم كان
ينتقد للاعب امام العالم الايراني انا
اتحدث عن دبلوماسيه كره القدم كما وصفتها
ما هي
التداعيات لهذه المباراه المهمه التي
افترض انك ست تشاهدونها وهناك سؤال اخر
وهو عن الصين سؤال صغير
وبسيط هل
تؤيد الولايات المتحده المظاهرات في الصين
التي تجري الان واا ما هو رايكم فيها
وسؤالي الوزير الخارجيه الرومانيه اشكرك
على استضافتنا في هذا الاجتماع
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكراريه
الولايات المتحده
واخرين يقولون انهم يدعمونا اوكرانيا
طالما
امتدت الحرب لكن رومانيا الى متى تستطيع
التحمل وهل تعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
والنيتو يقومون بما يكفي واخيرا هل
رومانيا تريد
عسكري دائم للقوات الامريكيه في رومانيا
عندما ياتي الامر لكره القدم
وصلت
الجديده المباراه
هذه المباراه بين الولايات المتحده وايران
وشاهدته
مباراتهم
وانا واثق من قدرات الفريق لا اعتقد ان
هناك سياسيه
هذه المباراه اكثر مما هو مجرد مباراه
ودعونا نترك المباراه تتحدث عن نفسها
بنفسها عندما ياتي الامر المظاهرات
مظاهرات
الصين ومظاهرات
ايران ايضا واماكن اخرى موقفنا دائما في
ثابت في كل مكان هو اننا ندعم حق الشعوب
في كل مكان للتظاهر السلمي وان يعبر عن
ارائهم وقلقهم واحباطاتهم
شكرا
سؤالك عن اوكرانيا ادعمنا اوكرانيا منذ
يومها الاول في هذه الحرب وهذا الدعم
انساني
وكذلك نقل الحبوب التي ذكرناها اييي 8
فاصل اربعه مليون من الحبوب هذا يعني
الكثير بالنسبه لتضامن بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهو يصل الى 16 مليون من الحبوب
تم نقلها
ايضا
اكثر من 11 مليون طن من الحبوب الاوكرانيه
هذا الجهد ضخم وسيتواصل
نحن سندعم اوكرانيا
لطالما ضد الامر سنواصل هذه الجهود ولاننا
نعتقد
دعم اوكرانيا يعني دعم امنك رومانيا
والشعب الروماني والاتحاد الاوروبي ومنطقه
الاطلنتي في الحرب على اوكرانيا التي
اطلقتها روسيا ليست حوله اوكرانيا او ضد
اوكرانيا وليست هجوم ضد امني دوله
المجاوره بل هو ضد امنا المنطقه امم
اوروبا
ههه تصميم الامني لهذه المنطقه فنحن ممم
معنيين بحمايه هذه الحدود وهذه الحدود
الامنيه
والمساله هي اننا على الخطوط الاولى في
مسؤوليه الدوليه لما يحدث في اوكرانيا
وهنا ايضا ياخذنا الامر الى مساله البحر
الاسود فالعمر الذي قمنا بهواصل فعله حول
اهميه همم البحر الاسود الاستراتيجيه لذلك
كان يجتمع اليوم
مع وزير الكهرباء
لنصف الى احتياجات همم اوكرانيا للاداره
منها
وتعزيز الدم من اجل دعم قدرات الدفاعيه
لاوكرانيا سيكون لدينا ايضا جلسه بيننا
من خلال
الحزمه الشامله لدعم اوكرانيا وه جود
سيتواصل بالنسبه لوجود الدائم العسكري
للولايات المتحده في رومانيا
تحدثنا هذه المساله عده مرات وتحدثنا فيها
خلال ثروات الماضيه لكن الان لدينا وجود
قوي للولايات المتحده في للقوات الامريكيه
في رومانيا
وتحدثنا عن قرارات قمه همم مدريد وكيف
يكون هناك همم وحدات عسكريه وتحديد
قوات الدعم من مختلف دول التحالف